françois paul et mathis journaliste
spécialiste des institutions européennes
on sent poulet mathis bonjour et merci
d'être en direct avec nous sur rt france
à leur première question comment
expliquez vous le succès de cette
campagne de vaccination
outre atlantique outre atlantique et
d'ailleurs au royaume-uni l'explication
est assez simple elle est due au fait
que à la fois le royaume uni dans lequel
d'ailleurs est fabriqué un des vaccins
astrazeneca et aux etats-unis dans
lesquelles sont également fabriquer des
vaccins aussi important que pfizer est
bien dans ces deux cas effectivement les
négociations pour obtenir très vite des
vaccins ont eu lieu très tôt bien avant
l'union européenne qui est finalement
après avoir obtenu l'accord des 27 a mis
un certain temps à pouvoir négocier une
un contrat complet avec l'ensemble des
vaccins
ce qui n'a pas été facile le problème
c'est de savoir est ce qu'il existe
aujourd'hui une bonne stratégie
vaccinale
c'est très difficile à dire d'abord
parce que le vaccin lui-même surprend il
nous surprend parce que il apparaît de
manière un petit peu différencié surtout
apparaissent des variants qu'on
n'attendait pas vraiment et puis il nous
surprend aussi parce que dans les
différents pays
les réponses à ce vaccin peuvent être
différents et puis aussi il ya le fait
que les populations elles mêmes entre
elles ne sont pas toujours aussi
adhérente à l'idée de se faire vacciner
des pays comme la france ont mis
énormément de temps accepté l'idée du
bienfait du vaccin et de sa nécessité
donc tout ça a expliqué le fait que le
démarrage finalement 17 opérations de
vaccination a été beaucoup plus lent
pour un ensemble aussi différents que
l'union européenne alors que des pays
comme la grande bretagne comme les états
unis et encore plus comme israël ont pu
engager très vite et de manière beaucoup
plus massive
une opération de vaccination voilà le
véritable élément qui montre la
différenciation entre l'europe d'une
part et entre royaume uni et autres pays
d'autre part
alors j'aimerais que nous reviennent aux
vaccins d'astrazeneca on a vu à plein de
rebondissements cette semaine on sait
qu'il y ait un véritable affrontement
jeu sur le sujet entre le royaume uni et
l'europe londres est accusé d'ailleurs
de garder ces vaccins pour sa population
et de retarder les exportations vers les
pays de l'ue en dépit des contrats qui
sont qui sont signés qu'en pensez vous
j'étais un des problèmes c'est un des
problèmes posés par le fait que
finalement l'union européenne au début a
obtenu des conditions de contrat un
petit peu meilleur que le royaume uni
qui pourtant héberge la principale usine
oxford de fabrication de ce mac ça en
fait le véritable problème c'est que les
royaume uni veut absolument bénéficier
de la priorité
or comme il ya eu des retards
logistiques dans la fabrication
astrazeneca
il ya eu notamment cette affaire pour la
création de nouvelles chaînes de
fabrication en belgique
et bien tout ça a compliqué les choses
et finalement les l'union européenne
s'est aperçu que le royaume uni
finalement empêché ses producteurs en
belgique finalement de distribuer le
vaccin sur le reste des vingt-sept et
finalement préféré garder pour le
royaume uni une part de ces vaccins
c'est bon ça d'ailleurs que l'union
européenne a sévi et l'union européenne
finalement menacent de prendre des
sanctions et de bloquer toute
exportation depuis les usines au sein de
l'union européenne vers d'autres pays
pour pouvoir faire en sorte de respecter
les contrats qui ont été signés avec
astrazeneca
donc c'était très important pour l'union
européenne de fixer les règles c'est
vrai que ursula avant d'aller yens la
présidente de la commission européenne a
été quelque peu surprise finalement par
le fait qu'elle ne pouvait pas disposer
de toutes les doses qui au départ été
promise
et c'est vrai aussi que la tendance
actuelle de la plupart des pays
c'est chacun pour soi mais d'abord pour
soi d'abord et avant de l'envisager
effectivement une distribution vers les
autres pays dans la question très
rapidement le royaume uni
fait plus partie de l'union européenne
finalement c'est une victoire pour ceux
qui on a milité pour le break site
je crois qu'on peut pas faire de rapport
vraiment circonstancié entre le départ
de l'union européenne et d'autre part la
sphère vaccinale ce qui est vrai c'est
que étant sortie de l'union européenne
boris johnson a pris la liberté
d'engager tout de suite des procédures
vaccinale puisqu'il n'a pas attendu
l'accord de l'union européenne pour le
faire en ça et effectivement il a
bénéficié un petit peu d'une avance il
va essayer d'en bénéficier
dans sa popularité ce qui est déjà un
petit peu le cas puisque finalement sa
relative réussite en matière vaccinale
va le conforter un peu politiquement
mais j'irai qu'on met une petite réserve
il s'agit bien de la première dose du
vaccin en grande bretagne
si on compare le nombre de vaccinés avec
les deux doses
la grande bretagne fait pas mieux que
les autres pays donc il faut en toute
mesure garder la relativité des choses
merci beaucoup en tout cas françois
poulet mathis d'avoir à répondre à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
journaliste spécialiste des institutions
européennes